Hi there, Ashley here. I am glad that you're joining me and learning about our product Natural ClearHist by Connors Clinic.
So Natural ClearHist is a blend of flavonoids, antioxidants, proteolymic enzymes, and botanicals.
This blend is known for stabilizing mass cells and diminishing the release of histamine.
It also reduces circulating allergic protein complexes and reduces the thickening amicus, which supports the airway and respiratory system.
It also contains immune boosting properties, as you can see in the ingredient list.
So potential benefits of taking Natural ClearHist would be for someone who's hypersensitive to help balance their immune system.
Someone who has cancer, it could help lower their histamine levels. It can support our sinus and respiratory health.
It can help with normalizing the thickening of the mucous, and it can also help with clearing the nasal passages.
So someone who would take this would be someone who has seasonal allergies or environmental allergies.
Or for those who have done their genetics, any of these genes listed below here, do play a role with inflammation, body temperature regulation, altered sleep patterns, and of course allergy responses.
This can also play a role with respiratory health as well, such as someone who's experiencing asthma.
So directions on how to take this, these are very generalized here, but you are more than welcome to follow that.
Or if you want, you could start with what's recommended on the bottle, two caps per day.
Or if you are someone who is sensitive to introducing new products to their system, then you might want to start with just one capsule and see how you do and work your way up.
And then as always, we recommend that you do touch base with your healthcare professional as well.
For kids, we have clear hist junior, which is the same as natural clear hist.
The difference is that this is a chewable, and also that the amount per serving is of course less.
So adults can take clear hist junior if they would like to.
We would then of course recommend matching the amount of chewables you would have to take to equal an adult serving size.
So might be a higher dose of chewables than to of course get to where an adult would need to be.
So comparing the two bottles would be a good idea.
You can find both those products, natural clear hist and clear hist junior on our site shop.conorsclinic.com.
You would just type in with magnifying glasses of the product name and it will come up.
Then you can purchase right on our site.
We appreciate you being here learning about our products and we thank you and we will keep you in our prayers as you navigate through your health journey.
Thanks again for watching.